[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL KINLAN: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to our second mobile
web, or Thursday mobile webs,
web mobile Thursdays, I can
never quite remember the name.
I'm Paul Kinlan.
I'm a developer advocate
at Google.
I'm working on Chrome and
Chrome for Android.
And I'd like to introduce
Pete LePage, who is--
are you in Mountain View or
in New York at the moment?
PETE LEPAGE: I'm in Mountain
view this week, enjoying the
nice weather and avoiding the
lovely snow that's going on.
PAUL KINLAN: Oh, wow.
Cool.
Sweet.
So we might as well
get into it.
So this week's episode is about
what's new in the beta
version of Chrome.
Chrome is now on M26
and Android.
Recently got updated, actually
twice this last week.
We've had a small, mind bug fix
that's actually gone out.
So if you're using the Chrome
beta channel at the moment,
you should actually just be
seeing the new update.
And I think it should
be available now on
the Nexus 7 as well.
We had an issue whereby we
hadn't actually set the camera
permission up properly.
We've re-rolled that out, so now
you've got access to that.
And you'll be able to see that
in the book tracker as well.
So it's all pretty cool.
It's pretty open.
But today we're going to talk
about a couple of really
interesting topics, some of
the new features that are
inside Chrome for Android,
the beta M26.
The interesting thing about this
is what we're going to
talk about today, it's not
really available to kind of
normal users at the moment.
But you guys who are watching
this today, you are the
cutting edge users and the
developers on this platform.
So we want to give you a little
bit of a preview into
what's actually happened.
And the two bits that we're
going to talk about is the
data compression proxy,
which has just
been basically announced.
It's all kind of
in Chrome flux.
It's not kind of public
at the moment.
And the second is getUserMedia
and WebRTC.
I can't actually show you
WebRTC at the moment.
I couldn't get it working.
But we've got some nice
little things to
show off like in between.
Like getUserMedia is one of the
best ones at the moment.
You've finally got access to the
camera inside JavaScript
inside your phone.
So that's pretty cool.
And we're going to kind of
show them off today.
So without much further ado, I'm
going to hand you across
to Pete, and Pete's tell
you a bit about the
data compression proxy.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
Awesome, thanks.
So the data compression proxy is
something that's brand new
to Chrome, and it's
something I think
that is pretty exciting.
Basically, the data compression
proxy reduces the
amount of network data that's
sent between your device and
the remote website that
you're asking for.
Now, just one thing to call out
really fast, right off the
bat, is that it only does
this for HTTP sites.
If it's a secure connection,
we're not going to do
anything with it.
We're going to let you go
directly to the server.
We're not going to get in
the middle of that.
But for nonsecure connections,
basically what happens is that
Chrome opens a speedy connection
between you and one
of the Google data centers.
And from there it starts going
out and making the
requests for sites.
So there's a couple of things
that are happening once you've
connected to the Google
services.
As you start going out and
making those connections,
we're using the new--
well, I guess it's not the
new, but the speedy
connections, as well as the--
I'm completely blanking on the
name for it right now.
Paul, do you remember?
That's what it is--
page speed libraries.
Every once in a while-- so I'm
here in Mountain View.
It's 8 o'clock, and I was--
yeah, it's a little early.
I apologize.
Anyway, it's the open source
page speed libraries.
So by using these page speed
libraries, there's a couple of
things that are going on.
Images get optimized
automatically.
So most images, when developers
push them up, they
optimize them a little bit.
But they don't always remember
to optimize them.
Sometimes they completely
forget.
Sometimes they just
do a little bit.
Well, what the image
optimization does is it uses
WebP to transcode the images,
which uses less bandwidth and
shrinks them down while
maintaining
the same image quality.
So your images just get much
smaller than what they were
before, and they're
always optimized.
The second thing that happens
is there is a set of what we
call content aware
compression.
So that's things like
minification, white space
removal, all of that
kind of stuff.
So taking all of the
stuff that--
normally, you might have a
JavaScript file that's this
big, and it's now all of a
sudden going to be this big.
Again, not every developer
remembers to minify things, so
this makes a pretty big deal.
And then the third big advantage
that you get out of
using this is that you get
access automatically to all of
Google's safe browsing
technology.
So we're making sure that the
sites people are going to
aren't sites that are spreading
malware, or phishing
sites, and all that
kind of stuff.
So there's really sort of three
main advantages, both to
consumers and to users.
Now, I was playing with this a
little bit earlier today on a
couple of websites, and you
could pull this up.
And I know Paul's going to
show a demo of this in a
minute or two.
You can see how much your
compression is turned on.
So to turn it on--
I guess we should start
with that first--
you need to go into
Chrome Flag.
So if you go into Chrome colon
whack whack flags, one of the
first items that you'll see
there is Enable Data
Compression, or Experimental
Data Compression.
So you enable that,
restarts Chrome.
And then from there, you can
start loading pages.
Now, to see how much stuff
changes, open up a new tap and
go to Chrome colon forward slash
forward slash, or whack
whack, net dash internals.
So when you go to the
net-internals, from there
you'll see a link where you
can click on Bandwidth.
And you click on that bandwidth,
and it shows you
how much data has been saved
by using the speedy proxy.
PAUL KINLAN: Shall I get that up
now on one of our screens?
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
If you can pull that up, that
would be really cool.
So it's a really cool way to
be able to see what's going
on, to see what's happening.
It's really fascinating
to see.
So we were looking at the
Verge earlier today.
And the Verge had about
a 35% or 40%.
Paul, do you remember
off hand, was it--
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, it's actually
45%, because I turned
it on just before this talk.
And it's the only request
I made, so 45%
saving for this session.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
So like 45% of the bandwidth,
right, is down.
So what was the total kilobyte
size on that page before?
It should say up in that box.
PAUL KINLAN: I think
1,900 kilobytes.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah,
so that's what?
1.9 meg.
PAUL KINLAN: Maybe 2 meg.
PETE LEPAGE: So nearly 2 megs
has been dropped to what?
PAUL KINLAN: So it says saving
6 watts, it's saved 663
kilowatts of that--
PETE LEPAGE: So like
1.2 megs or so.
It's gone down.
It's down to 1.2 megabytes.
Now, when you're on a nice
Wi-Fi or on a 4G
connection, eh, OK.
2 megs, not a big deal.
But when you're on an Edge
connection, or when you're on
anything else, that's
pretty significant.
This morning I was playing
with In Focus from "The
Atlantic" News.
And "In Focus" is one of my
favorite pages to read, or I
guess I kind of call
it a blog.
It's a collection of photos
that are recent events,
photographs from those
particular recent events.
And this morning when
I was looking at
it I got a 65% savings.
So I went from almost a 4 meg
page download to less than 2
megs
So you can see how much savings
you're getting because
you're taking all of that data
and making it smaller.
So not only are you getting
advantages in terms of speed
increases because you're sending
less data over the
wire, you're also potentially
reducing your mobile bill.
Because all of a sudden you're
not costing 4 megs.
And if you're not on an
unlimited plan, all a sudden
that's a pretty significant
thing.
There's a really great
document on this.
If you just go up and do
a quick search for--
PAUL KINLAN: We've
got the link--
PETE LEPAGE: Oh.
If we've got the link,
we can put that up.
But Ilya, who's going to be
doing a much deeper Hangout on
this in the next week
so, I believe--
just check
developers.google.com/live and
look for "make the web fast."
There's a great article, Data
Compression Proxy.
It goes into all the nitty
gritty details, and worth
checking out.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, definitely.
So yeah, it's on the screen
at the moment.
I suppose, can we just switch
across to my screen?
And I want to show you some of
the stuff just so you can
actually see it working
in action.
So this screen at the moment
is my dev tools, which is
actually connected to my device
which we saw on the
camera before.
And before we came on air, we
actually connect the Verge
just see what it looks like.
And the great thing about the
actual site itself is it looks
exactly the same.
It doesn't look any
different at all.
But this is how you can actually
tell whether you're
actually in the data compression
mode at the time,
is that it's gone into
speedy mode.
And there's the host, method,
and path in the call on scheme
as the request header, which is
different the normal HTTP
request header.
That's kind of the primary
indicator to the actual fact
that you are running
in this data
compression mode at least.
And that's pretty much
here, right?
You don't really notice anything
else, other than the
fact that it's a cache
and proxy in between.
So the really cool thing as well
is if you go back to the
site, the data is potentially
cached at the Google side of
things as well.
So the actual refresh itself
should be a lot quicker.
I just want to show you some of
the images, because this is
kind of the interesting thing.
PETE LEPAGE: While you look
for those images, Paul,
there's one thing I also
wanted to mention for
developers.
One of the things that I know a
number of developers want to
know is hey, is somebody making
a request, and is it
coming through this proxy?
So as a developer, is that
request coming through?
And there's one easy way that
you can tell, and that's to
look for the X-Forwarded-For
HTTP header in your request.
So if you see the
X-Forwarded-For, and that's
going to have an IP address of
the original user who made the
request, or the original users
who made the request.
So you can check to see if
that's coming in so that you
can find out hey, who was it
who was looking for this
particular bit?
PAUL KINLAN: The other thing I
was going to say, actually as
well, is we've got a
moderator as well.
So if you want to ask questions,
we'll pop--
PETE LEPAGE: Oh, right.
Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: We'll pop the link
up in a second, and you
can ask questions on anything
we talked about today.
I would say a lot of the data
compression proxy, Ilya will
be the best person to definitely
answer a lot of
these, if it's very technical
and detailed questions.
We're just kind of giving
you a little
preview at the moment.
But whilst we're in this mode
of giving you previews at
least, this here, this is the
first PNG that we found, the
Verge Android logo.
It's a PNG file, but as you can
see, the actual request
type, image4/webp.
And that's because the page
compression service
essentially has actually
gone off and done that
conversion for you.
So it's actually very nice.
It's pretty cool.
I noticed on my own blog--
and I wasn't actually quite
sure exactly what was
happening at the time, but
I noticed that the actual
content ready event fired half
a second earlier when I used
the actual compression proxy
than it did when I
wasn't using it.
So even on Wi-Fi, it seems to be
doing a pretty good thing.
But like Pete was saying before
in mobile, this is the
potential to actually
improve the mobile
experience quite a lot.
So with that, shall we jump
onto the getUserMedia?
And WebRTC?
OK.
So let's see if this works.
I have a file somewhere.
Hey, there we are.
So this is the shiny demo.
I think it's all done, if
you can see my desktop.
I'm going to put my hand
across it a little bit.
You can see it.
This is actually on an old
Galaxy Nexus at the moment, so
it's running a little
bit slow.
Hello, here we are.
There's our producer there.
Say hello.
That's Ian.
So the really great thing about
this actually is that
this is basically just the
normal getUserMedia API.
It doesn't require
anything special.
Other than the fact it's
actually behind a flag and
it's enabled via the WebRTC.
So you go to about flags.
If we show if off correctly,
up around this.
Chrome--
sorry about this.
I've got fat thumbs.
While it loads, this
is really cool.
And has it just gone white?
It's a white screen, isn't it?
There we are.
So it's certainly not optimized
just yet, and this
is why it's in a flag
at the moment.
But if you search for WebRTC--
there we are-- you can enable
WebRTC in the Chrome flags,
and then you can get
access to it.
So in this case here, this is
our just normal Galaxy Nexus.
It's going to reload.
As you can see, it actually says
Allow, props up, doesn't
take access to the camera
straight away.
And if we scroll down, it's
going to take a little while
on this screen at least, anyway,
because it's not the
greatest demo on this machine.
Actually, it's a really good
demo, just on this machine
it's a little bit slow.
And if I leave for a couple
of seconds it'll be fine.
But if I switch across to our
other demo app, I've actually
got it working here.
You should say Allow.
Oh, there we are.
It's actually come back.
We're fine.
It'll take a little while
to get used to it, but
yeah, we have it.
So it's pretty cool.
We can do a special Hangout
another time on pure
[INAUDIBLE] features.
We just wanted to let you know
that this feature exists.
Yeah, I think that's about it.
Pete, do you have anything
else to say about
getUserMedia?
PETE LEPAGE: No.
This is one of these
things that I
think is really exciting.
It's really going to
allow us to do, as
developers, a lot more.
We've been able to play with it
on desktop, and we've seen
some interesting uses
on desktop.
Now to actually put it on mobile
devices means all of a
sudden we can now start doing
things like, oh, I don't know,
make video and voice calls
without needing any kind of
crazy plug-in.
So there's a lot of stuff, and
it'll be neat to see what
folks do with it.
PAUL KINLAN: Sorry, I'm just
taking pictures of myself.
I should have had
a shave, is all.
PETE LEPAGE: Nobody says
you weren't humble, so
[INAUDIBLE].
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah,
I kind like this.
I mean, we've been asking for
this for a long, long time.
And we've had some basic
access by the camera.
So if you have input type equals
file, accept image
4-star, content, I think,
camcorder, it kind of works.
But it's not an integrated
experience.
And I think if we've learned
anything from the likes of
Instagram, for instance, this
built in kind of integrated
experience is what people want
from their web apps and sites.
And this is one of those things,
even at a basic level
for getUserMedia, it's one of
those things that's going to
be really exciting.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
So I don't know whether
it does audio.
That's the big question
at the moment.
I
PETE LEPAGE: I think it does.
PAUL KINLAN: It will do audio
with WebRTC, right?
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: But there's
no audio API.
PETE LEPAGE: But I wouldn't be
surprised if you can't push
that through the Web
Audio API yet.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
Well, we haven't got
it, have we?
PETE LEPAGE: Touche.
PAUL KINLAN: I think that's one
of the things that's like
a little bit unfortunate
to some extent, but
it's kind of cool.
There's going to be a lot
of things that come
off the back of this.
And there's the rest
of our studio.
The studio looks cool when we
dress it up, but when you look
at the ceiling it's
pretty crazy.
So yeah, that was it, really.
I mean, there's not a
huge amount of extra
features in M26 beta.
It's more about improving the
performance again, bringing
the platform more
up to parity.
And we're starting to do that
with these two new APIs.
PETE LEPAGE: Absolutely.
And it's also really about
trying to get us on to a
similar ship schedule.
Because eventually we want to
be on the same schedule so
that like, hey, Chrome
gets updated--
Chrome gets updated
across the board.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
So should we jump to
the moderator?
I don't know whether
we'll have any
questions or not, but--
PETE LEPAGE: Sure.
Actually, I think there's
one question in there.
PAUL KINLAN: Oh, cool.
Have you got it up or--
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, I do.
So the question is from
Bill in Mississauga.
And he wants to know if WebGL
is still behind a flag.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
I think that's the
biggest thing.
So basically this
is the thing.
I know the team are really,
really keen at the moment to
get a lot of feedback around
WebGL, WebRTC, if you're going
to play with it.
We're not trying to push
it that much at all.
It's very experimental
at the moment.
getUserMedia the same.
And the data compression
proxy as well.
So all three are super
experimental.
We just though we'd give a
little preview right now.
Because we want your
feedback, right?
We're not going to
push it out.
We're not going to tell
you to use it.
Like, hey, this is going to be
enabled just yet, and all this
type of stuff.
We don't want you
guys to do that.
But we want you to test and
give us a lot of feedback.
And that goes for WebGL.
I don't think we have a time
scale for when WebGL's going
to be available.
And I think a lot of this hinges
on the fact that we
want a lot of feedback, right?
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Do we know how this
performs across all the
Nexus range or all the
Android range?
I don't know whether we do, and
we need your experiences
to basically test
it on mobile.
Because this is like the--
I think Firefox has had
it, basically mobile
on WebGL and mobile.
But the performance
characteristics are completely
different, so the applications
that you design are not going
to work exactly the
same on desktop.
And we can't cater for it.
But we want you to go and test,
and that's why it's in
the flag, and that's why you
can go out and test it.
And I think the same applies
for CSS filters and some of
the hardware acceleration
as well.
So I kind of always think
anything that's in flux is
fair game to go and test
and file books and
raise issues on.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, I
agree with that.
PAUL KINLAN: [INAUDIBLE]
book.com, select Android OS,
you raise it, put a link in.
Either copy me in,
PaulKinlan@google, or
PaulKinlan@chromium.org, and
we'll get it triaged and we'll
get it through for the right
people to go and test it.
Because ultimately, we want
these features out.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
And that's one of those things
like if you're running both
the stable and beta, which is
what I do on my Nexus 4, I
keep both there.
And 99% of the time I find
myself in beta, because that's
where I want to be testing.
And I only go back to stable if
a page doesn't work or if
something's a little bit broken,
a little bit weird.
So I'd encourage people to
go to turn on the data
compression proxy experiment,
and use beta on a regular
basis, right?
Figure out how things work.
And as well, as you're going
through, you get a better
opportunity to test your sites
to see hey, how are things
going to look when we
get our next drop?
PAUL KINLAN: Cool.
So I think that's probably it.
I think we're kind
of wrapped up.
There was two major features
that we wanted to show you.
They kind of worked
pretty well.
WebRTC, I didn't want to kind
of risk it just yet.
Just wanted to show
you getUserMedia.
But we want to hear exactly what
you guys are working on.
We want your feedback on
a lot of this stuff.
We also want to know what you
want to hear about as well in
more of these weekly meetings.
I believe we've got Jake
Archibald on next week.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
PAUL KINLAN: And
if we haven't--
he's on next week.
I've just kind of nominated
him for it.
PETE LEPAGE: Awesome.
PAUL KINLAN: I think we're
going to try and
talk about dev tools.
Dev tools and performance
at least.
I know Jake's big on
those two areas.
And it's completely different.
It's a completely different
game on mobile
than it is to desktop.
So we're going to show you some
nice stuff, and show you
how to make faster web apps
and web sites on mobile.
PETE LEPAGE: Very cool.
PAUL KINLAN: Cool.
So well, thank you,
Pete, for joining.
I know it was early.
Thank you for everything.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
PAUL KINLAN: And thank you, Ian,
for being our producer
and kind of waving at the camera
when it all happened.
Oh, and--
PETE LEPAGE: Oh, oh
another question.
PAUL KINLAN: Right.
There is another question.
Not sure if you're reading
the YouTube comments.
You're right, I'm not reading
the YouTube comments, sorry.
Do you know what version the Web
Audio API will be shipped
to beta, and a rough
date, too?
On both those questions,
it's Tom Arden in
Portsmouth in the UK.
I don't have an answer
for that.
I can speak to Chris Wilson and
a couple of other people
to see what we might
be targeting.
But even then, it's not even in
about flags at the moment,
so if it's out six months down
the line or a year down the
line, it's completely changed.
I think the important thing to
say is that we want to get the
same version that's in
Chrome for desktop
in Chrome for Android.
But it's not even in about flags
just yet, so I can't
even say that we'll get
it any time soon.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
The one thing I would
say, Tom, go to the
Chromium bug list.
See if you can find that in
there, because I'm pretty sure
somebody's got that
filed as a bug.
If they haven't, go file it as
a bug, even though I know
we're working on it
at some point.
And then ask other people to
star it, because seeing that
sort of drive for things, and
understanding how important it
is to the developers, is
really important to us.
Because we really want to
prioritize based on what you
find most important.
PAUL KINLAN: Yep.
Cool.
And I think with that,
I think we're done.
Thank you very much again.
Thank you for watching.
We'll see you next week when
I rope Jake into this.
I know it will be fun.
I've just got to teach him
not to swear on camera.
PETE LEPAGE: Or we just need to
put him on a good 30-second
delay with a bleep out button.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
Cool.
Well, thank you very much,
and we'll see next week.
PETE LEPAGE: Bye, guys.
PAUL KINLAN: Bye-bye.